aujourd'hui on a peur parce qu'on a
voulu combien me mettre dedans on a
essayé de contenir une équipe qui
techniquement au milieu était un peu au
dessus de nous donc ça disait qu'ils
arrivent à trouver des décalages
maintenant on a eu les étagères par fo
falloir enfin respirer
ça nous fait du bien
faut pas se cacher dans l'école
j'ai des petites erreurs individuelles
ça hurle ça arrive c'est m
les paralyser
c'est resté serait on l'a pas été
nul là
que de bonnes choses je suis tout ça
fait chaud au coeur parce que qu'est ce
qu'il faudra faire contre contre cuba en
tout cas au niveau de la préparation de
ce match a bien récupéré
au niveau des jambes du premier match
passer à autre chose ni vraiment au
niveau mental c'est surtout ça qui
m'inquiète le plus et puis après
bien parlé
du groupe la croissance du groupe resté
soudé et bien écoutez les conseils du
staff à la discussion se serait
important entre les joueurs pour faire
pour des briques et ce match bien sûr
bien sûr déjà une petite réunion à la
fin du match avec le président et le
staff technique mais va falloir
continuer sur ce chemin là parce que la
victoire est impérative pour tous que
cuba